as always our recordings of our virtual
meetups will be available on youtube
about a week after the meetup and we
will post a message on meetup when the
recording is ready
next i am very pleased to introduce our
speaker today bing liu
bing liu is a distinguished professor at
the university of illinois at chicago he
received his phd in ai from the
university of edinburgh
his current research include interests
include lifelong or continual learning
lifelong learning dialogue systems open
world learning and machine learning his
previous interests also include
sentiment analysis fake review detection
web mining and data mining
he has published extensively in
prestigious conferences and journals and
authored four books one about lifelong
continual machine learning two about
sentiment analysis and one about web
mining
three of his papers have received the
test of time awards and another one
received test of time honorable mention
some of his works have been widely
reported in popular and technology press
internationally
he served as the chair of acm
sig kdd
from 2013 to 2017 as program chair of
many leading data mining conferences
he is the winner of 2018 acm
sig kdd innovation award and is a fellow
of
aaai acm and ieee
take it away professor liu
let me share my slide
can you see it
yes we can see your slides
okay um thanks for the introduction and
thanks for the invitation um so today
i'm going to talk about um mostly about
continued learning and also a little bit
about this autonomy how can we make the
system autonomous and in terms of
learning in terms of reaction as well
and we have a book about lifelong
learning but
it's a little out of date because in the
past few years and the movement has been
quite
quite fast but the basic idea um are
still still there
um so in the traditional machine
learning and we talked about this sort
of isolate a single task you're learning
one task you have a you know the task of
a piece of data and then you have a
machine learning algorithm which we call
the learner
and that producer model and the model
i'll be using application application
you've got a sensor and then you model
make some decisions you execute
some uh things in your
in your application
somebody has a question
okay
so you can ask my ask me questions
anytime
you have one
so the key weaknesses
of this particular paradigm of
classical machine learning is the first
one is the the closed world assumption
which basically means um what you see in
in testing will be exactly the same
thing as you see in 20 so you are not
saying anything new or normal
happening in application which is
normally
not true because in practice
when you go to do sort of your
performance task
you always see something unexpected and
then how do you deal with that how do
you learn about that
which will be part of the talk today
and also the previous task previous
learning algorithm so paradigm does not
really do
continuous kind of learning so you
basically focus one task you collect a
lot of data and then you learn from that
data and you build the model and then
you the model goes application and then
that's it
but we're going to talk about the
learning after deployment so the post
deployment
phase under you
this system i'm basically going to see
the real cases and in this process of
receiving real cases if you see
something unexpected something normal
and then can you recognize it and then
can you learn about it and how do you do
it how do you do it we're going to talk
about that
as well
so first thing i'll give you um a short
introduction introduction of lifelong
learning or continue learning so that
basically and
in the early days um people normally
call it lifelong learning but nowadays
mostly
in the machine learning community people
call it continue learning but in the
industry all this
industry and also when people talk about
it people like to talk about lifelong
learning if you love london it sounds a
little bit more
easier to say or whatever easy to
understand
but these two terms basically it's the
same thing lifelong learning or
continual learning
basically means the same thing
so what it means it learns a sequence of
tasks uh incrementally so
it's basically trying to simulate on
what human being is doing in terms of
learning i learned something today i
learned something tomorrow and after
that you and then this basically is a
sequential process and it is also an
incremental process okay it's not some
sort of thing you you put all the tasks
together and you learn together
which doesn't really happen in real life
it doesn't really happen um often in in
real life unless you're doing sort of um
learning by intro instruction so some
teacher teach you something and you
learn from that you can learn lots of
things together okay together
so the goal of this level of learning
essentially
is to try to learn this incrementally
and without
uh catastrophic forgetting which
basically means when you learn a new
thing
are you going to forget
what you have learned in the past or are
you going to interfere with what you
have learned in the past this is a very
important problem is a very very
challenging problem especially for
neural nets so we're talking about the
neuron as one neural nets we're going to
learn all the tasks so sequentially
learning individual tasks and then if
you do this incrementally which
basically means when you learn this new
task you don't really have the training
data for the past tasks maybe you have a
little bit but not a lot
and then when you learn this new thing
you're going to change in your neural
nets right you're going to change the
the weights and the parameters and then
to suit this new task but
those weights and those sort of
problems that they were learned already
for the previous task so when you learn
new tasks if you
cause some change to those
my problem is that nine years are going
to sort of cause some forgetting which
basically means the degradation of the
accuracy or whatever measure you use
of the previous task so you you may not
be to do the previous task well so this
is one of the major challenges and
they're still still very tough to to
solve this problem
now another sort of objective is the
knowledge transfer when you have um
when you learn the new task
you obviously want to use the previous
task knowledge you learned in the past
to help you learn this new task better
okay let me know it's two times better
here's the new task we call it tm plus
one
and so the assumption is once the task
is learned the data of that task will no
longer be accessible so it's just like
what we humans do you know when we see
some let's say we see some chicken
something i will learn the recognized
chicken but tomorrow and i see some
rabbits i learned the rabbits i mean i
don't really have the chickens
those videos in front of us in front of
me anymore
and
so that's making the problem difficult
because you cannot learn everything
together because the data you have seen
before
they are no longer accessible
and that's also the problem because this
uh cash draw forgetting and also the
problem with transfer because what you
have learned becomes some network
parameters on those things standard and
you don't have the data and then the
knowledge transfer becomes tricky
because you don't know which
which thing which part of knowledge can
be transferred which part cannot be
transferred
so if you do not do it carefully you can
get negative transfer which basically
means you want to use the pass but the
past because it's going to hurt you
it's going to hurt you
so i hope you get the idea so we're
learning a sequence of tasks and the
incrementally that's essentially um what
the lifelong learning uh is doing okay
that's three and so if you see this
pictorially and then we have this uh
task t one t
up to tm plus one and this is the new
task or the current task you have the
current task data so the all the
previous tasks has been learned and now
you go to continue learner and then you
have the knowledge base okay this
knowledge base basically then
stores the knowledge you learned in the
past
and then when you have this new task you
want to have some knowledge which is
suitable for this particular task and
that can be used to learn this task to
produce a better model a better model so
that model goes to again goes to an
application okay so this is a sort of uh
sort of traditional
um
lifelong learning or continual new
paradigm
paradigm
so there's a few characteristics and
we're talking about the continuous
incremental learning process which is
essentially what the way we can do as a
human we do this quite well but
currently computers still cannot do that
and one of those big issues uh we
described is the catastrophic forgetting
so you basically you learn the new thing
you forget what you learned in the past
and of course and this of course
involves knowledge accumulation because
we learn so many tasks we want to
remember them and we wanted to remember
them and then defining the most
knowledge transfer of course this
knowledge transfer can be the full
transfer and can be backward transfer
forward transfer basically means
what you have learned in the past can
help me to learn the future tasks better
and the backward transfer basically
means when i learn the future with a
future task i can improve the model
for some previous tasks because
they might have lots of similarities and
they have some shared knowledge about
them so you can do that um so they can
do background forward um but in most
cases and
it's pretty challenging especially the
backward transfer because
uh if you want to do back transfer
you're going to change the previous
model and the previous data is no longer
there and then
this
can get very very tricky and very tricky
so if you don't do carefully you can
again you can you can hurt the previous
model and how to create
and so
there are many um there are several
settings there's actually many settings
for let's continue learning
and um so at least the first thing we
need to understand is that they are all
learned in a single neural net so what
is the idea here the idea is basically
saying we human beings are only only one
brain we assume that's a big neural nets
like big neural nets so everything i
learned in this single brain you are not
like in the past would build build sort
of individual models so for example when
i
do this um svm i know those these are
all individual models so the models are
completely isolate they have nothing to
do with each other
of course they can't help each other
unless you want to more physically
say i'm going to use something from that
previous model but the in the in this
neural nets kind of uh um sort of
scenarios we want to have this knowledge
transfer everything
down
done
automatically automatically
so there's two kind of setting which is
more
most popular one is called a class
incremental learning or class continue
learning
and that is let's say you produce a
single model from all the tasks
so what do we mean by a task a task
basically means there's a few things i
want to learn for example today i want
to learn i probably got some training
example of chicken and rabbits okay
today i run i got this two
two um two classes or uh two category of
things and i want to learn how to
recognize those two guys
and so this can be regarded as one task
so tomorrow i may be
saying uh i may see a dog for example so
and then i'm gonna learn the dog so that
dog is also on task
but of course in the day uh you can you
can see a dog and see a goose for
example you can learn them together so
that's the task
so you can see that we have the first
task of the chicken the rabbits and the
second task will be the dog and the
goose for example
and then so we have we have two tasks
okay so the class continue learning just
basically says uh we although we have
two tasks but i only have one model so
what that means basically means when we
come to the test time i give you an
animal and can you tell me
which one of this four
animal it is
okay so we don't really have the task
information anymore it's not say when we
learn that twist we have two times but
when we test it
there's no task anymore we just
basically try to recognize those four
type of animals
okay
so that's the most challenging situation
and then this is also of course what we
human can do very well on the weekend
we can learn to recognize something
tomorrow we'll learn something else and
after that we'll learn a lot of stuff
and there was not much interference now
we one way of learning the past we
that's still there okay
as time goes by you still can recognize
those things you're learning
in the past but this is a major problem
for for for lifelong on your continued
learning because you can cause quite a
bit of
uh forgetting which basically means uh
what you can what you've learned in the
past
and that classification becomes sort of
uh sort of become worse quite quite a
bit worse okay
the second one which is popular is
called task continue learning so this
one is more like you learn each task
separately
basically although we're still doing in
a single neural nets but
somewhat separate basically means
that each task they are they are not
they have nothing to do with each other
so when we when it comes to test time i
have to tell you which task
i want to test
so now you basically have the task
information the show previous one we
don't have the task information for
example today i want to recognize i want
to do some class classification of text
documents okay i have let's say our
politics and sports on the computer on
this thing that i want to learn i want
to recognize basically i want to
classify this kind of text but tomorrow
i learned to recognize animals
okay or maybe the day afterwards i wrote
i classify the sentiment for example i
give me a document is that possible is
this a positive review isn't it's an
active review so you can see this task
can be quite different
and but they'll learn in the same
network and then in this case you have
to give me you have to give me the task
because i'll give you a document you can
classify this that politics documents
the sports argument but you can also
classify in terms of sentiment okay in
terms of sentiment so it depends on what
you want
and i can use the model to
to perform the task that you you give in
terms of
time and time of testing so you can see
that there's a difference so the first
one is just that you
at the test time you don't have any
information on the task
but in the second situation of the task
incremental tasks continue learning
and the training time while the task and
the test number will also have the task
information so the second one is
actually much much easier
and actually the second one is pretty
much solved to myself you don't really
have much of a forgetting in terms of
cut or strong forgetting it's pretty
much solved the only uh issue in this
case is a it's a knowledge transfer
because some of the tasks you learned in
the past can be related to what you
learn in the future in the future so in
that case
and how do we
figure out which task will be similar to
that future task
and then
to transfer knowledge over
and that is still a challenging problem
and uh because it's not easy to identify
which one is which one is similar which
one is not
similar so now the problem of course is
the class incremental learning which is
very um commonly done as humans but is
very tough for for computer
and also is one of the biggest challenge
for practical application of
of continued learning because most of
the continuing application in real life
application is more like class
incremental learning okay for example
you have a self-driving car you go to
driving the road on the road that you
you probably learned to recognize
pedestrians you like to
recognize the cars and trucks all these
things but now i see something for
example i see a piece of leaf flying
flying in in the air so now
that is sort of uh another thing you
need to learn incrementally for example
you have never learned that before but
now you have to learn that so you learn
that next time when you when you go to
when you go to drive you see a piece of
leaf you should be able to recognize a
piece of leaf you will still be able to
recognize your
original possessions all those cars and
trucks all this thing they are all
together but that that's a lot of
applications like that even in the in a
chatbot kind of situation when we do the
chat about we basically say let's chat
about a lot of skills for example this
one can tell me the weather information
another one and booking
tables
on the rest in the restaurant and
another one can probably help me to
reserve hotels
but
and the next time i want to learn some
new things for example i want to learn
how to how to sort of uh book a flight
okay and how to sort of uh buy a print
ticket for example so those things are
those basically those are using
incrementally learned but when you come
to the common application i mean the guy
the the user is not gonna it's not gonna
tell you oh i'm gonna use that
particular task i'm gonna use this
particular type of booking train tickets
okay uh to to buy train tickets but i
would just say you know okay buy buy me
a train ticket and then you have to
figure out what my intention is so
that's essentially a class um continue
learning problem okay i'm not gonna tell
you you know i you oh now i'm gonna do
this particular thing other than you
only focus on this thing don't worry
about other things i mean i'm just
telling you something and you just do it
for me so my intent has to be classified
and classified so that becomes the class
continue learning problem and that's
very very challenging very challenging
so there are many approaches and many
approaches and there's a regularization
based approach and that's machine
learning so you want to regularize
basically you try to penalize changes to
that brownness so what happens that we
want to so we have really learned many
tasks and then those parameters has been
sort of fixed for those guys in the past
so when i adding a new task i want to
sort of try to keep the previous promise
at least those problems important to the
previous tasks okay so what is the
regularization is doing
when you have a loss function you add
some regularization it's a penalty
term which basically try to say if you
change the previous stuff
and i'll penalize you so you not you'll
try not to change the previous that's
the previous parameters and then when
you learn the new one so of course what
you can do is basically you find out
those those parameters which are
important for previous tasks
and try not to modify those guys too
much
and so those those
those parameters those neurons which are
not so important for the previous task
then you try to modify those guys
okay so try to model those guys because
they are not important to the previous
task so in this case we're trying to you
know try not to not to damage the
previous not to interfere with the
previous task problem is too much
um so the second second exercise second
one is the experience replay so this
basically means i'm
i'm i'm going to save a little bit of
data not much on previous tasks okay
because when i have when i learn this
new task i don't have
if i don't have anything from previous
stars this is very challenging and uh
but if i do have a little bit of data
from the previous tasks i randomly
sampled some previous training data and
now i'm going to learn this new task and
i now i can join the learning orders
together so there's a small amount of
data from the previous task can help me
to adjust the previous
sort of the parameters to make sure
those parameters that the problem which
has been changed
for me to learn the new task and also
suitable for the previous task
and again this is also not good enough
because
if you save not so not a lot and then
you may not be able to
just enough to to not forget anything
okay there are lots of lots of lots of
sort of uh
sort of algorithms another one is the
generate replay i generate the pass data
because i don't really have the previous
data but i assume i have a generator for
example the human can do this quite well
for example i see a dog tomorrow when i
see a chicken i see for example i see a
wolf and then which is somebody tell me
that's not the dog
and that's it's called a wolf and then
you can certainly imagine you guys oh
the dog is not this part is different
from the from the dog from this uh from
the zoom off
because you can generate something and
although you may not be remembering
exactly the dogs you've seen it before
but you do have an image of the dog
right sort of you can generate in your
your brain somehow and also most people
some people even can draw it right and
then they can join the basically they
build some kind of generator in their in
in the brain so
so this is essentially trying to use
that kind of approach way and the one
that i learned to recognize that
particular animal at the same time i
learned how to generate that animal
images okay and animal image so when i
learn a new task i can use those
generated
things
to help me
um to learn this new thing and also to
adjust the previous
uh previous time the previous tasks to
make everything works works well okay of
course generation is not perfect you so
you generate something different
and again which is quite some problem
because
and if the generation is not perfectly
suit sort of the previous thing and then
you cause some sort of forgetting as
well
another one is called the prompter
isolation these are these four are
fairly popular
and parameter isolation is mostly for
this particular thing for task continued
learning and
essentially he says i'm going to do iso
i learn this particular task
i will protect it for example i can use
masks
so for example this bunch of neurons are
very important for this particular task
i musk in this guy i said this guy's
already been ticking
somebody have used this one already so
if you want to learn a new new task
don't touch those guys okay you can use
those guys which basically in the
forward pass when you do the neural nets
when you do the forward pass you can
still use those guys um but when you do
the backward pass when you do the back
propagation you cannot change those
weights okay when you compute the
gradients and then you want to do the
um sort of
the sgd and then you you basically
should not change okay
you should not change those guys so this
becomes uh isolated so
this
in this case and
then you can pretty much fully protect
the previous tasks you learned and in
this case if i do know the task
information and then i can say oh okay
i'm going to use this particular task
now
for example i'm now going to do the
sentiment classification so i'm just
using this
this this is sort of a sub network
essentially some network and then um
which is not going to cause any
forgetting so i can do so as i first
does it i did it okay i know when i
first did it now and later i want to do
it and that's still pretty much the same
i'm not saying so this is the one this
is basically the main approach which
solves this this particular problem
tasks continue learning
but of course this is not suitable for
the for the first one and for the first
one because you mean you protect it
and that's no use because i uh and at
this time i'm not gonna tell you which
one which model um which model you
should use so you still have to choose
which model and that's still a problem
can i still have quite a bigger problem
how do you choose okay how do you choose
it's pretty uh pretty complicated
and this also have
two kind of two kind of a mode
um the one is uh
batch continuing another it's online
content learning so batch continuum
basically means
i have all the data when i
when i start to learn this particular
task so for example i already manually
labeled a lot of data when i have this
new task for example i'm learning the
rabbits and i've got a lot of gravity
images okay i can learn this pretty good
task and then i can learn to recognize
this thing quite well
in one go so in the training i have a i
can use a large v box okay i do a lot of
epochs to
to perform my training to
divert the the laws down but online
saying in a situation is more like a
continually streaming data comes in
streaming
so your
the data basically comes gradually and
yeah when you see a little bit of data a
small batch of data and then you have to
train your model you have to update your
model so as time goes by you basically
um update your model minimum many times
many times and this is the data comes in
streaming and you only can see the data
once and then every time um you
basically you you train with that small
amount of data essentially like you are
turning the data in one epoch in one
epoch okay so that is of course is much
more challenging and you can't achieve
very good results because you only only
change one epoch effectively but you
emotionally uh into the batch container
you can train a lot of epochs and then
obviously you can learn a more
more effective model okay
but in real life many cases are like
sort of
um like continuing because for example
when you see something you see some
dog today and you learn that and then
tomorrow you see some different dogs and
you say oh that is also dark then you
learn that so that just becomes online
kind of situation because you you don't
really learn
all the dogs together in today's season
dog you learn it tomorrow you think
about you you sort of improve your model
today you maybe see some black dogs
tomorrow you see some white dogs the day
afterwards you see some small dogs
and then because the data comes sort of
um gradually not you don't see all the
data together and so that makes the
problems even more challenging and more
challenging
so most of our applications still not be
able to know the application um still
pretty much lagging because a lot of
technical problems not solved and i'm
technically probably not solved so i
just give you some example of
this
pre-deployment continue learning okay
post-deployment just basically
after the model has been deployed can i
still
have a stimulant because most of them
most of the situation when we talk about
machine learning we are always talking
about pre-deployment because we
basically build a model the model is
really working very well and damn i'm
gonna send for deployment and to do this
to do it is intended performance task
okay
so let's talk about this batch
convenient learning okay just i'll just
give you an example it was published
last year um
so this is trying to deal with scatters
or forgetting and then we learn one
thing at a time and for example i know
and recognize learn to recognize chicken
necks and they recognize dog and then
after that or learn to recognize the
sheep and those things okay you one
class at the time
and so this is essentially this is the
um sort of a problem of
um of uh continuous per task continue
learning okay this is even more
challenging because in traditional um
sort of supervised learning you have
more than one time you you have more
than one class you can compare with each
other right but when you only have one
class this becomes very challenging okay
how do you learn this particular class
because you have nothing to compare with
okay that's the comparison
so in this case we essentially propose
uh
uh
uh kind of um
mostly mostly the contribution here is
mainly about this holistic
regularization the first part of it is
essentially the negative negative
likelihood negative long-lasting stuff
and that is not so much but
there's the second part which is that
what we call the holistic recognization
what does that mean just basically means
we we don't want to
want to have this model which
uh choose only biased features
to recognize this particulars we want
this certain features to be spread get
to be spread so equally important so you
have lots of features and the other
features are sort of not necessarily
equally but
similar to each other not some some
features very important that some
features become less important so that's
why we penalize the gradients pretty
nice gradient if the gradient is too
large because i risked the power too
many and then you
want to bring it down okay we want to
bring it down so it makes everything so
evenly used sort of uh
all the features that you may use so in
this case essentially when we have a
feature extractor and then we can use
each of this into learning individual
model individual model for to recognize
each individual class
and then this
we can learn sort of individually and
this does not have any forgetting it's
not any forgetting however
if you learn individually you don't see
other guys and when you come to the
classification that becomes the problem
because you
you you you can only say this is not me
this is not me oh this is this probably
is me so you have to compare this thing
you compare that
the the sort of magnitude of your of
your output response
output response and which is uh also
cause some challenge then there are some
details we
we try to it was that and i'm not going
to talk about that so of course the
result is pretty uh it's much better
than um then without using this
particular organization organization
and this is another one which is the i
don't know
the previous one previous this one is a
class incremental learning so i'll give
you another example which is uh
it's also a batch continuous learning
but it's a task incremental learning so
in this case we say
we're learning the video tasks and and
the test time we also
know which class model we want to use
okay for the previous one we don't know
and we don't know but now no and we know
so in this case much easier
and so in this case we're dealing with
both problems of forgetting avoidance so
we don't want to cause catastrophic
forgetting and that we also want to know
the knowledge transfer kinetic transfer
essentially in this case we learned a
bunch a lot of tasks and so
i will learn a new task we want to want
to know
which previous task model can help me
to learn better okay better because it
could be a lots of reasons it could be
the data and the amount of data is not
sufficient or you can some kind of cases
you did not cover but that was sort of
similar to something you've learned in
the past
so this essentially we're going to deal
with both problems that deal with bus
problems and so
um
so the the
the
technique to deal with the first problem
of forgetting is based on some masks so
it's basically we identify
a sub network
okay to identify some network work for
that for each particular task
okay
and as we as i said that just this is
essentially
an approach uses a parameter isolation
okay from the isolation approach
and then we identify some tasks this
particular problem and then particular
sub-network for this particular task
and
the forward you have no problem you can
use it either backward you cannot you
cannot change it okay you cannot change
it um nco for being blocked for the
previous task so in this case the the
challenging is the knowledge transfer so
how do i know
some some previous task is similar to my
current task
i can use that to help me to learn
better for the current task so in this
case we're talking about the forward
knowledge transfer and the backward
knowledge transfer
so one way to detect this is uh we built
a reference model so essentially say
when i
if i don't use any of the previous
knowledge and then what can i achieve
can i achieve but if i do use some
previous knowledge what can i achieve so
essentially when i try to compare these
two things if one guy is doing better
than
you if i use something in the past that
can help me to do better i think that is
sort of similar similar to my new task
which is probably going to give me some
knowledge transfer
and so in this case when i learn this
new task if i know that and learns new
tasks i can open the sort of open those
um
um so those masks
so i can show them
when i learn this new thing i can learn
i can open the mask of those old tasks
which are similar to me
okay and then i can sort of update those
guys as well and all at the same time
learning myself so in this case of
course we can when i learn myself okay i
can do some forward transfer if i can
modify the path a little bit
which which basically achieves backward
transfer uh transform knowledge okay
transfer essentially that's essentially
the idea
so after we detect the mercedes
architecture we know the task id so we
essentially this is a task oriented okay
on testing when you learn incremental
learning and we know the classification
heads on the saints and then we detect
those
similar uh tasks similar to us use this
particular thing to do it and then um we
detect we find those things similar then
we essentially we use some kind of in
some more things so the attention sense
to put things together to help us to do
uh to do better with this new task okay
and so this is just something some
results it shows um it does it does
better okay that's better i'm not going
to talk about this without much
okay
and so i also want to give you a
example for online continuing so the
batch container says when i have the
task i have all the data already so
continue learning is that when i have
the task but my data comes slowly it
comes slowly and uh i have to basically
get a small batch of data and start to
train okay keep training keep training
that the model okay so in online and
this is the thing we are going to
publish
soon
it's called online content learning
based on mutual information committee
information so the objective is again to
deal with a deal with a
catastrophe forgetting cmp is a casual
forgetting
and cl is sort of class incremental
learning so the class continue learning
okay it's the same same thing
um so what we want to do in this case is
uh when we learn
every task of the learner each iteration
each of a small batch of data we want to
prevent the information loss in future
learning okay and also at the same time
we want to preserve the previous
knowledge
okay
and so we need a new kind of learning
strategy i'm not going to talk about the
theoretical analysis here but just that
what is the idea okay the idea so i'll
give you um a problem description first
and uh now i'll tell you what the idea
is so in this particular case and we
have the training data and then we have
the i actually already said essentially
the data comes gradually comes gradually
and whenever a small batch of data
denoted by an x new
and there was a small number of samples
normally 10 for example 10 samples
and then from a particular task of t and
then it's accumulated and then it will
start to train in one iteration okay and
then the data is basically turned away
it gets right away
and then we see the next one and then we
turn the next bench next match keep
going
until we finish this particular
task the date of this particular task so
this in in this online continued
learning
very interestingly the online continuing
almost every algorithm uses replay what
do you mean by replay as i said just now
essentially for the previous class i
saved some data okay i'm not saying i'm
going to destroy i'm not i'm going to
discuss all the data
from the previous task i still save a
little bit can save a little bit data
from the previous task okay i have a
memory buffer i can remember about the
same those things
and then when i get this mini badge and
uh to to do this uh to do the training
my mini branch consists of this is the
new x news basically this is the new
data
x buff is is from the buffer so this is
a sample from the buffer under which i
saved for the uh for those data i've
seen in the past i guess after that and
this memory is called that we use the
template code is memory
and then we join the train this this
thing together okay
together so then of course in the normal
sort of neural nets we have the feature
extracted and when
the
classifier
and then we to use this to have to
formulate the loss function on the state
so the problem um when we do this mutual
information and the main issue is this
problem of
uh for crossing to be actually it's not
just quantum entropy but this is true
for any sort of loss function you use
for classification so the popular and
the cross entropy is the one the popular
uh probably the most popular sort of
loss function for for supervised
classification
um so what this what this guy does
essentially
is to identify those discriminative
features okay you learn the descriptive
features which is able to separate the
classes of each task
okay
so this is what we call the
discriminative feature is just basically
to try this based on this bunch of
features i can separate
the classes that i'm learning
and we say this is biased because
you might be sort of forgetting about
you you may you may sort of neglect many
features which is not necessarily
important for this particular
classification for example i see black
dogs and white chicken so i learned this
probably color is good enough i don't
really um because all my training data
and the dogs are all black and all the
trinity data of the chickens are white
so then i don't really need to know the
shape or whatever of this chicken and
the dog i only need the color okay i
don't need the color which is good
enough
but
tomorrow i see a white
uh rabbit
then that feature you learned in the
past is no longer valid it's no longer
good enough right because that's white
that's white but it's a rabbit it's not
the chicken all right so that is the
problem which is causing the forgetting
because what you've learned in the past
is not good enough for my new classes or
new tasks new classes so if that is not
good enough in order to learn the new
one you have to modify the previous
um sort of parameters you can practice
in the union uranus and that causes
forgetting okay we're forgetting so one
way to deal with that to at least do to
illegally to sort of reduce the effect
of that is straight we try to learn the
full features okay full features
so don't neglect anything you think is
not important for your task but that
feature although it's not important for
your task but it can be important for
future tasks
okay if that is not there when you learn
the future tasks then the future task is
going to modify you
and then that's cost forgetting okay
so
mutual information is able to help us a
little bit on that help us to some
extent on that of course not completely
okay so this is essentially the
idea i just give you a rough idea it
says i want to learn the
this is the classified part okay the
classifier let's don't worry about this
part
and that we are talking about the
feature we want the features to be
holistic basically means i we don't want
to lost any features i don't want to
lose any features so the features the
input will be this
this is basically the
x new and x buff right and then we have
the head this is essentially the loss
function comes here
for for learning the features containing
features so here is the mutual
information we want the new the original
data
and the transformed thing the transform
is saying go through this network
transform thing we want those things
like mutual information we want to
maximize the mutual information so when
you when you talk about the machine
information you're talking about the
dependence of two sort of um
sorry two random variables right two
random variables so in this case we want
those two guys to be sort of uh very
correlated with each other they're not
going to be i have these ten features
but i only learned one feature so then
they are not really you know they're
sort of not that uh depending on each
other and but we want these two two
things to be to be uh to to maximize
this mutual information okay so to be
dependent on each other very much will
depend on each other
and for the for the new data and also
for the buffer data so in this case
with this
mutual information maximization uh we'll
be able to
sort of learn more features rather than
learn only that
only those things which are probably
good enough for discrimination of this
particular task
so we want to learn more one more
features
so in the same time we have this
particular line here and what we want to
say we also want the mutual information
to say we want to preserve those guys
okay
which you learned in the past we want to
show essentially what you have learned
in the past and the way you are learning
now we want them to be similar to okay
we want them to be similar to okay so
then we can if we can do this and then
we'll be able to um sort of cause less
forgetting okay because less forgetting
and the cause of course less
modification when you run a new task and
the feature part the feature you do not
have to change a lot of those features
because i've tried my best to learn all
the features impossible i can and now if
you if you have a new thing which is the
features probably i'm learning the past
the feature is good enough for you right
but you you just have to change your
classifier that's fine because the
classifier part you have different kinds
of reasoning head you're not going to
forget anything in that case so the cost
the issue of getting is basically in the
future range okay in the future learning
and then we have some results which can
sort of come can sort of result in the
major an improvement in
difficult tasks and somehow easy task
because you don't improve much for the
more difficult tasks you can you can you
can gain quite a bit of
um
so this is the last of three lines uh
our sort of results results and uh just
different
uh different kind of variations kind of
for our thing and you can see it's quite
a bit of lots of info just
[Music]
um okay so
um
so
now i'm going to talk about the
post-deployment of continued learning
post-department convenience basically
means now
i have run this model
and i'm going to
put this model to application okay and
then to put this application
and in the process i'm doing an
application i probably see something
i've never seen it before
so how do i learn at that time so
basically it's on the fly okay on the
flight learning okay learning
so we also call this the open world
because the the world is
when we talk about normally
classification or supervised learning
we're talking about closed world so
which basically means um the what you
have learned
will be what you are going to see so
whatever you are going to see
you must have seen them in training in
testing must be uh must have happened in
training so that's the case so in this
case we're saying
when we see the real world we'll see
something unexpected yeah i've never
learned it before how do we handle that
okay so this is very important and in
the past two days i went for workshop
we're talking quite a bit about this
okay i want autonomy okay so you can
learn by yourself you don't have to ask
some humans asking the human soul
engineers to collect lots of data and
then you learn can you get all these
things by yourself can identify the task
and also at the same time get the
training data and learn incrementally
okay incrementally so for example in the
self-driving car right if you are um if
you work on this particular problem you
are you will probably know this is
extremely difficult you know it's
extremely difficult because a lot of us
see lots of things you see in the real
life uh it's going to be unexpected okay
when i i work on this particular problem
for one year so when i was working on
this problem
and uh sort of in the evening i thought
about the algorithm and then next day i
want to draw a draw drive to school i
said oh no this is not going to work in
this kind of situation so every time
it's like that i'm never saying yourself
sort of any idea is oh this is good at
least for my home i know i'm not talking
about a very complicated situation from
my home just just completely expressed
way a little bit of a little bit of
certified in in the city area but most
of the time even in expressway it's
really oh my god my algorithm is not
gonna work okay it's not gonna work
because something unexpected happens
so this is really tough to
cover all the corner cases okay in the
real situation so can you learn on the
fly when you see that unexpected you can
learn it at that time
okay don't ask me don't ask the
engineers to basically to drive back to
the today uh to the lab and then and now
there was some more data all those kind
of thing takes a long time to do and can
we do that and that's all i can
this slides just give you a particular
real real case
my my personal experience as i said i
consult for for a company self-driving
company for one year
and so once we took the car for for a
few tests essentially on the road and on
the road
and when we um sort of when we are close
to a sort of a t-junction the car
suddenly stopped and just refused to
move and then we look in front and the
back and the left and the right there's
nothing because
of course we did the test on the roads i
mean all those railroads but uh it's not
a busy road i mean that's not many cars
so at that particular time there's
nothing there's nothing like there's no
car there's no no traffic at all and the
lights everything was good then the guy
just refused to move okay then we have
to manually take over and then we drive
the car to the lab and then go to debug
what what happens what happened what's
going to happen then we find out while
the sensors detect a small pebble on the
road
just to take people we look at the world
we didn't really see anything because
that's the pepper is pretty small and
they're pretty small i wouldn't see
anything
and then
then then we have to go basically have
to change the program and then you know
label some data and now you can learn
this
next time when you see this power don't
stop me anymore okay
and so but what happens if at that
particular time the car
has already detected this thing right
the car tell me okay i detect something
i expect that in this particular
location
and then what should i do
okay at least
as the humans or the what is the
passenger always the engineers now we'll
just basically say oh that's safe just
go ahead
okay so then that car just can go ahead
at the same time learn
this particular type of object is not a
problem okay not a problem so in the
future
you don't stop anymore right so this
becomes a learning on the fly so in this
case you can see
as a human i'm doing some supervision
but this supervision is kind of a very
natural supervision and it's also free
you don't really i don't really you
don't need to pay me to label this data
right the car does not pay me to label
this data but
if you go back to the lab
you have to get somebody to label this
data and because the engineer normally
don't do this i guess normally you you
get the civil war country that people in
the village you know to mark this thing
you know this is a small pebble you know
you don't
you you basically label a lot of this
and say oh don't don't
that's this guy you can recognize that
but it's not the problem
so when we do this on the fly
it's free it gets free but this is not
true this is not easy to do it's not
easy to do okay as we said the
incremental learning itself is already a
major problem okay this is essentially a
class incremental learning
because previously when we when we uh
the perception system learned to
recognize all kind of object you never
sort of thought about oh god you have to
recognize this small pebble now we
basically try to realize no this is a
human now this is like um this is the
truck this is the bicycle you know this
kind of stuff never sort of said oh
there's a little thing in front that we
we need to recognize but
of course later on we have to we have to
cover this part and to learn all this
stuff
they can if we can do the same on the
fly you'll be very good i mean the same
thing in the chat box situation you can
have a situation so you build chat bots
and then somebody say something you
don't understand let's chat about this
knowledge that we're gonna do when
you're stuck there or just say oh i
don't know but can you learn okay can
you learn
by
sort of uh have a dialogue with with the
person which is talking to you and
talking to you but that's what we do
right when human beings when we say or
somebody say something we don't
understand it we say oh what do you mean
by that right or what do you mean by
that do you mean this or do you mean
that
if the guy basically tells you it means
this means that then you'll learn that
right next time you don't have to ask
the guy anymore okay so can we
accumulate knowledge in this way so this
if we can do this that becomes the
system becomes autonomous okay of course
we still cannot do this yet but we have
some simple examples to show um we have
some uh it's possible to do
to some extent
so again we're talking about the
continued learning and uh this in this
case we're talking about the open world
and we're focusing on post deployment
we're talking about application time of
application so in this case we have this
origin lines okay orange color lines
these are essentially the ones we we
need to do in order to do this close
word situation so sorry the open world
we need to discover new tasks and we
also get the ground truth data as well
if you're going to choose data and then
of course some knowledge you can put in
the knowledge base so in order to learn
you have to get your own task new tasks
you don't this has not come from the
human engineers okay and also get your
training data yourself for example just
now you're asking stop you're asking the
the passengers say oh is this what is
this thing is this safe okay in the safe
and then engineer says it's safe let's
go ahead and you learn it right
so the previous thing i'm not going to
repeat it because
the bold part that we already talked
about before so the the new new thing is
just they basically say we have to
identify new tasks and the background
choose training data and learn tasks
incrementally so you can see this we
close the loop right we don't have any
losing part you when model goes
application unless it gets get into the
sync right and it can't do anything
anymore but not that's not true now we
in the application we can also discover
a new task and then you changing data
and then we close the loop but then
system will become autonomous okay
because autonomous
and so this is essentially
the post training thing
and this is also the same situation for
humans right we learn a lot of stuff on
the job right we don't really
learn everything from our training from
education right when we go to work and
we learn more i learn more about in that
case in that particular situation we
don't really have a book or we don't
have the instructor but we can talk to
each other right to to learn the same
yeah so we want to put this into uh into
the ai agent ai system
so this is also an example let's see
um existing for example this is we're
talking about the greeting um but um how
much time do i have do i still have
um if you could wrap up in a couple
minutes that would be yeah i'll try to
try to be quick okay and so this is an
interesting example okay here's an
interesting example it says um it's a
greeting bar in the hotel and so for
example in a hotel lobby you have sort
of a chat bots over there the mobile
chatbots basically creating a guest
have some small talks with with the
guests so for example then ted was seen
this existing guest says hello how are
you today right but what happens if you
see the new guest
okay and
the system has to recognize this guy is
new which essentially is creating a new
task to learn right this is a new person
i have to learn this person so that's
the creating a new task then you want to
get some information about this person
right for example welcome to hotel and
then you say differently and what your
names are and so the guy may answer oh
my name is david and then you get the
class label of this guy and then you
take some pictures and then you can
basically learn to recognize this david
right next time when you see david again
and then you can say oh hello david how
are you today right so basically means
you're you recognize this person and
then you you you basically can talk to
this person just like a friend and so
you can see this this becomes completely
autonomous autonomous
and then i think um this is basically
the framework and how do you do this i
think i don't really have a lot of time
to talk about the first i'm going to
talk a little bit so this involves quite
a few things okay when you have a
problem and uh when you see something
expected you have to characterize it
what is it yeah what is it this thing
okay
and um you cannot just just say i don't
know anything about it okay and disable
and also have to adapt to this thing and
also to learn from this i have to learn
from this
and of course you also have to access uh
assess the risk and risk if you if you
say something you may say something
wrong right for example you see a piece
of furniture you're going to say what's
your number sir right that's that's
crazy and that's terrible you're saying
you're not good enough at least you know
that's a person now you can say that if
you see an animal you see a piece of
piece of furniture lying around in
the middle of the lobby you cannot say
what's your name sir right and so this
is the essential you need to
characterize and that you need to adapt
and so how do you do how do you get your
information the grant choose data
essentially you can ask humans you can
ask him to to do demonstration others
can perform some kind of limited
reinforcement learning
and
so okay i'm going to skip this
this is a pretty complicated i'm just
talking about one
final thing we built a little chat box
system and this chatbot system
essentially says um um when i um
basically i'm doing something uh for the
for the for the user just like siri and
alexa and you say for example and tell
me the weather today and actually i will
tell you you know what's the temperature
of those things and uh our system is
essentially doing that essentially it's
a kind of command sort of a user
natural language interface for the user
okay and then what happens if the user
say something i don't understand for
example um i say
um switch off the lights
the
the guy does not understand maybe the
guy only understands turn off the lights
for example and then if
the channel does not understand that uh
switch up the lights so the chat bots
you're going to see oh um so whichever
for example switch off the let's have
this example just give you an example
list
so if i go so
um let's say that the chatbot
understands switch off diets but they
does not understand the turn off the ice
in the kitchen or turn off the lights so
for example the cm system is our system
which basically cannot understand this
so this is like an already detected you
detect a new task okay i don't
understand i did a new task this task
has to be learned so next time um if i
learn this thing next time i'll have no
problem
so how do i characterize this because i
need to i need to basically acquire some
information from you but i cannot say i
don't know anything about this right i
must sort of say sort of saying that
which part i know which part i don't
know right and then i can ask you
something specific about this part i
cannot just say oh i don't understand
this can you tell me what is it and then
that means the guy may tell you
something else or you still don't
understand
so for example you know
uh
you know the switch on the lights switch
up the lights right
but in this case there is a ton of light
so it's a different word and then you
see oh okay so switch off lights is
something very similar to what you said
right switch on switch up the lights in
the kitchen switch on the lights in the
kitchen and uh which one do you mean
okay which one do you mean so in this
case the guy may answer oh i mean to to
switch off the lights
oh okay then the system will understand
turn off light means the same thing as
the switch on the lights so next time
now you can center and turn off the
lights and then the system will have no
problem okay no problem so this is
essentially a continued learning it's on
the fly yeah i have some short
communication with uh show the dialogue
with the human and i get this and next
time i will not have a problem with this
particular
sentence okay of course you need to have
manage the risk you don't want to
ask people too many questions people get
annoyed and also
if you don't know anything if you you
don't you don't want to give some user
some sort of random options right you
basically don't make and you you want to
be safe you say okay you say this you
have another way okay so don't get the
bad reviews right you're saying this guy
doesn't understand you doesn't
understand anything right and uh so
anyway so there's a lot of interesting
issues involved in order to learn
sort of on the fly and to make system
autonomous
so let me just just close
and essentially we say in the
traditional
of machine learning without a closed
world and a single task of learning and
then we don't learn anything um in the
open world which basically means a post
okay a post deployment okay so we want
the agent to learn continuously in the
open world and on the job on the fly
after deployment so to close the loop to
make the system autonomous so you need
to discard new tasks and get the brown
tools data and continue learning by
everything by yourself
by self initiation and self motivation
so don't ask engineers to to
to sort of label data change model and
rerun the algorithm whatever saying
however the current technique is still
in the infancy and it's pretty
challenging it's pretty challenging and
but i think some of these things are
sort of ready for for some applications
these are simple type of applications
uh thank you very much